dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly on IFA here earlier
we have talked quite a bit about a
fantastic new tool that we called
artistic style transfer this means that
we have an input photograph that would
like to modify in another image from
which we'd like to extract the artistic
style this way we can for instance
change our photo to look in the style of
famous artists now artists individual
effects industry spent a lot of time
designing the lighting and the
illumination of their scenes which is a
long and arduous process this is
typically done in some kind of light
simulation program and if anyone thinks
this is an easy and straightforward
thing to do I would definitely recommend
trying it after this lighting and
illumination step is done we can apply
some kind of artistic star transfer but
we shall quickly see that there is an
insidious side effect to this process it
disregards or even worse destroys our
illumination set up leading to results
that look physically incorrect today
we're going to talk about a flamboyant
little technique that is able to perform
artistic style transfer in a way that
preserves the illumination of the scene
these kinds of works are super important
because they enable us to take the wheel
from the hands of the neural networks
that perform these operations and force
our will on them this way we can have a
greater control over what these neural
networks do previous techniques take
into consideration mostly color and
normal information normals basically
encode the shape of an object however
these techniques don't really have a
notion of illumination they don't know
that a reflection on an object should
remain intact and they have no idea
about the existence of shadows either
for instance we have recently talked
about diffuse and specular material
models and setting up this kind of
illumination is something that artists
in the industry are quite familiar with
the goal is that we can retain these
features throughout the process of star
transfer in this work the artist is
given a printed image
of a simple object like a sphere this is
no ordinary printed image because this
image comes from a photorealistic
rendering program which is augmented by
additional information like what part of
the image is a shadowed region and where
the reflections are and then when the
artist starts to add her own style to it
we know exactly what has been changed
and how this leads to a much more
elaborate style transfer pipeline where
the illumination stays intact and the
results are phenomenal what is even more
important the usability of the solution
is also beyond amazing
for instance here the artist can do the
stylization on a simple sphere and get
the artistic style to carry over to a
complicated piece of geometry almost
immediately
temporal coherence is still to be
improved which means that if we try this
on an animated sequence it will be
contaminated
with flickering noise we have talked
about the work that does something
similar for the old kind of style
transfer I've put a link in the video
description box for that I am sure that
this kink will be worked out in no time
it's also interesting to note that the
first style transfer paper was also
published just a few months ago this
year and we are already lavishing in
excellent follow-up papers I think this
demonstrates the excitement of research
quite aptly the rate of progress in
technology and algorithms are completely
unmatched fresh new ideas pop up every
day and we can only frown and wander at
their ingenuity as usual please let me
know in the comment section whether you
have found this episode interesting and
understandable if you felt that
everything is fine here that is also
valuable feedback thank you and by the
way if you wish to express your
scholarly wisdom our store is open with
some amazing quality merch have a look
we also have a huge influx of people who
became patrons recently welcome thank
you so much for supporting two minute
papers we love you too thanks for
watching and for your generous support
and I'll see you next time